(wings flapping)
- Don't (beep) on me.
(happy, upbeat whistling)
- He's a keeper.
- It was love at first sight
when I saw her, I knew.
- There she was with her
chocolate brown eyes,
and looking cute and making
cute little squawking noises,
and I got her.
- We were walking by the kitty
cages, and all of a sudden,
Melvin kind of reached his
little paw out and grabbed me.
- Having these photos
would just be a memory
that I'll always have of how
happy I am when I'm with her.
- And I've had her for 12 years,
longest relationship, yeah.
SO, this is an opportunity
forme to tell people,
rescue a parrot if you want a parrot.
- [Becca] Melvin is a kitten,
he's only four months old,
so I think having him in
this age and me in my age
is like gonna capture the time
when we kind of got to know each other.
(camera clicking)
- [Stu] In my spare time,
I'm a pro bono attorney
for a couple parrot
conservation organizations.
As I've gotten to know more
about African Grey Parrots,
I realized if one must have
one, they should rescue.
But they're taken out of the
Congo by the the hundreds
in crates, most of them die,
so many people give them up.
And once you have a parrot in your home,
for the most part, it's
too late for that parrot
to ever be in the wild again.
Yeah, I've kind of made it my mission to
get people to reconsider.
If they don't have 900
square miles for a cage,
then they probably shouldn't get a parrot,
and if they must, definitely adopt.
There are tons of them
out there that need homes,
and they're super, super loving.
- I had a 21 year old cat named Blossom
who passed away in August.
And, I never thought I would
ever get another cat again.
He is very hyper and
energetic, which is great,
but it's kind of like a
baby where you have to watch
him or he gets into stuff.
All in all, it's an amazing experience.
I have a little built in best friend.
(camera clicking)
- I heard this dog screaming outside.
And, the gardeners had come
that day, I guess the gate
got left open, I was
like, "Oh no, that's her."
I ran outside, she had been hit by a car
and this car had just kept going.
When I ran up to her,
her tail started wagging,
because she was just happy to see me.
Her pelvis was just totally shattered,
and they told us that
we could either operate
or put her down.
What do you want, you want this?
In 2015, I was diagnosed
with a hip condition,
like I woke up one day and I
just couldn't walk anymore.
When I finally went in for surgery,
I just kept thinking,
Ella also had pelvic reconstruction.
And if she can do it,
and she's this small,
then I can do it too.
Tell 'em who's boss.
This dog is the love of my
life, like I cannot imagine
what my life would be like without her.
(camera clicking)
- So, today is the unwrapping.
- Never had pictures of Chiku
before done professionally.
Just what my apartment needs.
(paper crinkling)
- Oh, you're a model.
We can put this in your portfolio now.
- Chiku. (laughing) It's great.
(paper crinkling)
- Oh my gosh, it's so beautiful.
Oh, so cute.
- This embodies us perfectly.
I think that these photos
showing us together,
all healed up and so happy,
and we're just two goofy gals.
(laughing)
- Best pals. (laughing)
We're very handsome, I love
it, this is going on the wall.
What do you think, hey Chiku.
(mouth popping) OK, I think she likes it.
- I feel like we look
the same in this picture.
Like our eyes are very
similar, and he's 100% my son.
I never saw the resemblance before,
but now, it's pretty clear,
like, this is my guy.
- Yes, you should 100% get
a pet photo shoot done.
I mean, you can take
pictures on your phone
or take Instagram stories,
but having these printed out
in high quality, this is
something I'm gonna have
in my house forever.
My kids are probably gonna
look at this one day.
(camera clicking)
- Um, I'll probably leave this to her
so she can remember me when I'm dead.
(whooshing)
(hinge squeaking)